BARRET SCHLOERKE:
OK, so Future's
a wonderful R package
that does a lot of voodoo
behind the scenes so that
you can easily run code
in a separate R process.
And I think that in itself
deserves a ton of praise,
because the API is so
simple, and is so useful.
I actually don't even
use the shorthand API,
because I like the very
direct, explicit future where
you say, hey, run this
code in the future,
and then go get a value.
And I think that in itself
is a wonderful handshake,
and I really like this and I
really enjoy embracing this.
This is very useful if
you have, like, hey,
I want to run 100 simulations,
and I have 10 cores.
Let's make a plan
to use all 10 cores
and just churn over those.
And we can actually use R
on all separate 10 cores,
or in 10 different R processes.
Hopefully your machine is smart
enough to use all the cores.
But typically R is single--
single worker is the way
I want to think of it.
And so if it's a single worker,
you churn through it serially.
But if we are able
to use future,
we can now churn through it in
parallel, using as many workers
as we have available.
And I think that's awesome.
It works out really
well, and we can actually
take a quick peek at this.
So we library(future),
and then we
can set up plan and
say multisession.
It's just a good
default. Then we
can say workers is two
for the demo purposes.
Or for the other example,
I could set it to be 10.
I know that works
great as well-- or 100.
It doesn't matter.
But two works.
And then here, I have my
simulations from 1 to 10
that I want to run, and I'm
going to create the future,
I'm going to set up the future.
I'm going to say it was
created, and then I'm
going to return
that future object.
And then finally,
at the end, we will
look at all of the values
for each of the vals.
So let's library plan, run vals.
And it immediately goes
into-- the first two
are created right away.
And then we start to go through
this just a little bit slower,
but in pairs of twos.
And that's really neat.
If we are looking at
it with a Sys.sleep(2),
that should have taken
what, 20 seconds?
But if we do a start is
Sys.time, and end Sys.time--
what is it-- end minus
start, maybe this will work.
Try it again.
So it took 10 seconds.
And this is awesome,
we have two workers,
and-- oh, it took nine seconds.
Not really 10, but
we have two workers,
and it all finished up
very quickly in parallel.
Not 20 seconds, that's
the important part.
We can get in later to where
that extra second went,
but I'm not too worried.
It's roughly 10, so
that's the good part.
And if we get the
values, we have 1 to 10.
Perfect.
This is really neat, but one of
the things that was interesting
is, when you noticed-- when
you watched how it was working,
I could not actually
execute this end.
Or this end minus
start until the lapply
had finished processing.
That's little weird, because
I'm saying, hey, dear future,
please run this in the future.
And this is because it
actually had ran out
of workers to submit jobs to.
So if I switch this, and I
say workers is 100, plan.
I start, do the vals, end, it
should go much, much faster.
Oh, it-- let's
actually cancel that.
Let's say workers is 10,
because it's actually
making a hundred R sessions.
We don't want to do that.
So let's set it up to be 10.
So now they're
created very quickly.
And so let's actually
just redo the whole thing,
because I didn't even
hit the end time point.
So it took two seconds.
Submitting the jobs
is not trivial.
It takes time, but
it's a lot faster
than if we are to
do this in serial.
So, that's good.
And we can look at the values.
Everything is great.
So that's a lot of fun.
It's really neat how all
of that is able to be done.
But there's that
funny situation of,
when you run out of
workers, and what happens
when we run out of workers.
And my thought is it just
immediately returned.
And turns out, it
actually blocks.
Blocking has very
big implications
for Shiny and for Plumber.
Shiny will actually
treat future processes
very similar to a promise.
And a promise is
a thing in R that
says you can chain
these promises,
but you can also
kind of interleave
the processing of promises.
Promises kind of
jump into later.
But the idea is that
you can interleave
the processing of promises.
So if you have a job that takes
a very long amount of time,
you can actually break
it up into a chain
of multiple promises.
And that would allow other
things to work in between,
rather than waiting for your
job to finish completely.
This idea can also be
scaled up for Shiny
in that, what if we have
multiple users coming in?
If this user comes in and
says, please process my model,
and it's one big block
of code, no one else
gets to do anything.
All of your cores are
being underutilized.
Nothing.
And so instead, you could
use promises to say,
if you could break up
that section of your model
or processing of that model into
multiple, multiple promises,
then other users
can come in and just
say oh, give me "Hello, world!"
Give me "Hello,
world!" and no problem.
They don't have to
wait till the end.
So I think it's really cool.
Future, we treat just like a
promise, and it gets upgraded,
and the result is
handled accordingly.
The bad part is, future blocks
when submitting a job if there
is no workers available.
So there is a brand new function
in the promises package called
future promise.
And a future promise, for all
practical purposes, is just,
I promise to execute
this in the future.
So for the majority
of what you'll do,
whenever you'd normally
say future parentheses,
you can kind of replace it with
future promise parentheses.
So in our code, if we were
to come in here, and--
let's actually copy this
and make a new script.
And library(promises),
and we'll clear out.
our output.
Right.
So we say library(future),
library(promises),
set up our multisession.
Let's actually adjust our
workers back down to two.
OK.
And then we will adjust our
future to be a future_promise.
And let's try running this.
So the time finished right
away, and it actually--
I was able to get control back
to the console right away.
And then these messages
started just showing up
when it started completing
and submitting these jobs.
And I think that's a
very subtle difference,
but it's a very
important difference.
Because, if I run this again,
of calculating the vals,
I can actually come in
here and say 1 plus 1,
say 2 plus 2, 2 plus 3.
And I'm able to submit this work
while waiting for the future
to finish.
And now my main R
session is not blocked.
This is super cool.
This is that "wow"
moment, because now I
can process other
people's work while not
waiting for that big future job
to finish, or to be submitted.
And that is very,
very beneficial.
So workers is an
arbitrary thing.
You can set it to what you want.
It's dependent on what
you want to use them for.
So if you have things
like submitting data
to my SQL, or not
labor intensive tasks,
but you need to do
a bunch of them,
then maybe you have two to
three of the amount of cores
that you have.
Because they're not going
to be utilizing that much
work, and it's OK.
You could even go higher
than that, if it's not
a real intense task.
But if you're counting all
the numbers in Fibonacci,
and it's very computation
expensive, then maybe you
do cores minus 1.
So if I have eight
cores on my machine,
I might say workers equals 7, so
that I can click on my computer
still.
Otherwise, you'll have all
of your cores maxed out,
and your computer's kind
of rendered useless.
But it's up to you as to
how you want to use it.
Workers are not cores
directly, but your computer
will try to offload them and
have them process, because it's
not in the computer's
best interest
to put them on the same core.
So Plumber.
Plumber runs on httpuv,
just like Shiny.
So a lot of these concepts
were just the same
as if we were doing Plumber
API or a Shiny application.
The concept of working and
using futures and promises
just extends from
one to the other.
So in Plumber,
let's imagine that I
have two functions that I
want to expose in an API.
Plumber is a R package
that will allow you
to create a web API
from R code, just using
a couple of little decorators.
In this case, I
have two functions,
the fast calc and slow calc,
and I can expose them as routes
with the @get/fast/
and @get/slow/.
And for me, in the case
of the demo for this,
the id is just representing
the submission order,
but the calculation
can do whatever
it wants with the
parameters, things like that.
But then that way, when you
see something like slow /1/
and slow /2/, we
know that slow /2/,
is submitted after slow /1/ even
if they are very close together
in submission time.
Cool.
So Plumber handles
this, and in this case,
we're going to have four routes.
We're going to have a fast
route, a slow, a slow, and then
a fast route.
And if we are to process it, all
four submissions kind of done
at the same time, it
would look like this.
Because R has only one worker.
So we do the fast route,
and then it responds.
And then OK, it's done.
And then we do a slow route,
and then it processes,
and it takes a very long time.
And no one else can do anything,
and slow /3/ is just sitting
there waiting to do work.
Then it's done, and
then we respond.
Great.
Slow /3/ comes in, and
it starts to process,
and it is very slow.
And it's taking its time.
And fast /4/ has to wait for
all of this processing time
to work.
And then OK, we're done.
And then now we can respond,
and then fast /4/ can come
in, and it processes
really quickly.
And then it can
respond, and we're done.
So great, awesome.
Those four requests came in,
and they took about 20 seconds.
If we think that slow takes
10 seconds to calculate,
and fast is roughly
instantaneous.
So the fast comes in, the
process is right away.
Slow comes in, takes
10 seconds to process.
And then slow /3/ had
to wait that whole time,
and then slow /4/
had to wait even--
all 20 seconds for
it to be processed,
even though they kind of
arrived at the same time.
This red area is bad.
This is something
that we can optimize.
I can't necessarily make
slow calculation faster,
but I can reduce the waiting
time, and that's a goal.
So with Plumber, we can
do this using future.
And this is just talking
about using futures,
and so how they can work
with Plumber and with Shiny.
A lot of people
don't know of this.
So if you're compiling
a PDF in Shiny,
if you return a future from
your reactive, or your output,
or an observe, it will
put it in this promise,
and it will listen to it.
It's awesome.
I read the docs, but you can
offload things quite well.
The only change
in this situation
is that we're going to wrap our
slow calculation in a future,
and then we will resubmit it.
And from before,
it took 20 seconds.
And now it will take 10 seconds.
And there's been-- fast /4/ got
reduced by 20 seconds total,
and slow /3/ did
not have to wait,
and so it was 10 seconds faster.
So all the wait time in this
example was able to be removed.
We can't reduce the
processing time,
but we can at least remove
or get rid of the wait time,
and that's awesome.
And so this is how future
can help you do that.
Cool.
So how would this look
like with Plumber?
Plumber is typically,
or is always,
in the main R session
or the main worker,
and we can add extra workers.
Future worker one,
future worker two.
So having those
same routes come in,
where the slow is actually
wrapped in future,
it will look like so.
Oh, yeah.
The future worker, we're only
doing it in the process step.
So OK, fast comes in, it is
processed really quickly.
Great.
We respond, awesome.
Slow comes in.
Hey, it's a future,
let's offload it.
Great.
This allows the main R process
to come in and do the same
thing with slow /3/.
Since we have enough workers
for the jobs, then slow--
or sorry, fast /4/ is able
to process immediately.
Slow /2/ just
happened to finish,
so that we can send it off.
And same with slow /3/.
A lot going on, a
lot of moving parts,
but it's really nice
because it allows
to offload that slow
processing somewhere else
to free up that main R worker.
So you can respond
to health checks,
you can have other users in
Shiny do simple reactivity,
and it's not going
to be a big deal.
You're not waiting
for someone else
to finish running their model.
Why should someone else's Shiny
session alter my Shiny session?
And futures and promises
will help you do that.
So that's where we get
that 20 second save,
by being in parallel.
So some limitations.
You were talking about
how many cores do I do?
Well, we saw I was trying to
add 100 cores at one point,
and my computer
just kind of blew up
a little bit, because it
was spawning 100 R sessions.
Maybe not the best idea.
Two to three is pretty
good, or one to one
if you're computationally
intense preprocessing.
Spawning a future
is not instant, kind
of like a quarter of a second.
But if a quarter of a second
really doesn't mean much to you
for time, then
future is perfect.
If a quarter of a second
does mean a lot to you,
maybe don't offload it
to an external R session.
Because maybe that communication
overhead is too much,
and you're already losing time.
So and that's kind of where it
leads into the processing power
is finite and memory
size is finite.
Maybe if your models take
up 10 gigs of memory,
maybe you only use two workers.
It's still better than zero.
What happens when I
run out of workers?
So let's pretend we
have six slow routes all
being handled by future.
And what would happen
if I slow three,
we will run out of workers.
So slow /1/ comes in,
offloaded worker one.
Great.
Slow /2/ offloaded worker two.
Slow /3/ blocking
the main R session.
And the main R session
is still blocked,
because now slow
/4/ is blocking,
slow /5/ is still blocking
the main R session.
Slow /6/ is still blocking
the main R session,
because it can't be
offloaded somewhere.
Now it's been offloaded.
Fast /7/ is still blocking
the main R session,
but it's kind of free.
And then now we can undo the
result of the future values.
And now the main R session is
unblocked, it's kind of free.
Phew.
Now we can process slow /5/,
and now we can process slow /6/.
But while we are waiting to
offload slow /3/, /4/, /5/,
and /6/ to offload
the new workers,
the R process was not usable.
The main R process.
So in the case of Plumber,
you cannot do a health check.
In the case of Shiny, I cannot
load up a new R session,
or a new tab.
It's blocked,
nothing can be done.
And if we are to visualize
this, the processing time
takes 30 seconds in
total, offloaded in pairs.
And there's actually a new thing
where the result of slow /1/
and slow /2/ do not get
returned until 20 seconds in.
That was when the main
R session became free.
And slow /3/ and
/4/ had to wait,
slow /5/ and /6/ had to
wait, fast /7/ had to wait.
And that's not good.
We want to try to reduce that
wait time as much as possible.
To add in as well,
this is the area
where there were more future
requests than future workers.
This is also the area where the
R session plus the final end
is where the R
session is blocked.
The main R session.
That is where
things are unusable,
even if you're only just handing
them off, or you're waiting.
This gray area is bad, and
we'd like to minimize it
as much as possible.
Cool.
So this is where
future promise came in.
Promise that executes
using a future.
If we were to do this
with future promise,
the execution time
would look like this.
The items slow /1/ and slow
/2/ respond immediately.
Slow /3/ and /4/,
just like were before.
But the big one is fast /7/
is now actually executing
immediately.
It is not waiting for anyone.
Fun animations, and also,
more fun animations.
The big difference here is
where the gray bars are at.
In this case, the gray bars
are only at the start when
we're resolving the
values for /1/ and /2/,
and resolving the
values for /3/ and /4/.
And also for /5/ and /6/,
can't get rid of those.
But in between, completely free.
You can run health
check routes on Plumber,
you can start new
sessions in Shiny.
You're not blocked,
everything is awesome.
Any time you say future
parentheses, just
say future promise.
Solve a lot of issues,
and for the most part,
as long as everything's
scoped just like it should be,
then everything will
behave as expected.
For the most part, it's
just a one to one drop in.
For comparison, let's
see how the animation
works for this one.
So we have all of our /1/
through /6/ slow routes,
and then a fast route.
And the addition
here is that we're
going to have this
promise queue of a promise
to compute with future.
So it's a prequeue,
not a post queue.
So we have this prequeue because
there's no workers available,
so we'll just say I will--
I promise to do this.
So we can now execute
fast /7/ immediately,
and then slow /1/ and slow /2/
have finished processing after
10 seconds.
And the order may be
a little fuzzy here,
but for the most part, they
go in and out in pairs.
I just-- you can only
animate so well in Keynote.
Yeah, but throughout
the whole process,
the main R session
is free like 90--
98% of the time, not
blocked 60% of the--